hace pocos días
preparándome para esta fecha tan
importante
que atraviesan el mandato de presidente
de la nación
leía una frase
de gisela castillo y la manera basan
hijas de ex combatientes de malvinas
hijas de mario ramón castillo y daniel
bazán
con esa frase sintetizaban mucho decían
orgullo y gratitud hacia nuestros padres
pensé en esas dos palabras
orgullo orgullo por nuestros
combatientes nuestros caídos y nuestro
legítimo derecho de soberanía
pensé en la palabra gratitud gratitud
por haber dejado una huella imborrable
en la historia grande de nuestro país
pero también lamentablemente debo
agregar desde mi lugar
una tercera palabra horror por la
terrible irresponsable decisión de una
dictadura que mandó a la muerte a
centenares de compatriotas que con
valentía y coraje defendieron la
soberanía argentina
en
1540 años del desembarco de tropas
argentinas en nuestras islas malvinas
quiero que mis primeras palabras sean
para los soldados que dejaron su vida
para sus familias para todas las
veteranas y los veteranos
que sufrieron postergaciones
cuando hace pocos días decíamos con
fuerza y decisión
nunca más
también lo extendemos a nuestros héroes
y heroínas de marina para que nunca más
vuelvan a caer en el olvido y el
silencio de parte de ningún gobierno
a todos y todas quiero expresar la
solidaridad y acompañamiento ante el
dolor y mi agradecimiento
profundo sincero honesto como argentino
como ciudadano
por haberme representado
en aquellas luchas
como el joven que era entonces por
llenarme de orgullo por esos jóvenes de
mi generación que actuaron en únicamente
y hoy como padre porque no debemos
olvidar que allí
con ellos fueron detrás muchas familias
argentinas
sé que con esto solo expreso aquello que
es un sentimiento compartido en nuestro
pueblo
los reconocemos los recordamos y los
honramos como héroes que han sido y que
son
la argentina
los argentinos
y las argentinas convertimos una misma
convicción decir las malvinas son parte
de nuestro territorio nacional
las malvinas siempre fueron argentinas y
jamás seremos nosotros reclamos
decía que en esta última semana
recordamos también
primero el 24 de marzo en ocasión del
día de la memoria la verdad y la
justicia y luego también
y por ahí
adquirido amigo lorenzo pp
recordamos los 40 años de la histórica
marcha bajo la consigna paz pan y
trabajo
convocada por el movimiento obrero el 30
de marzo de 1992
recordamos los tiempos de la dictadura
más atroz que sufrimos los argentinos un
tiempo signado
por las persecuciones políticas
las desapariciones forzadas de miles de
personas
la represión y la imposición de un plan
económico que sumieron la pobreza a
millones y endeudó de manera criminal a
nuestro país
en esos días en ese clima social y
político insoportable
la junta militar que entonces había
usurpado el poder decidió en un intento
desesperado por conservarlo contrariar
la larga tradición diplomática argentina
de negociar en los organismos
internacionales
y desembarcó con nuestros soldados en
malvinas
nada bueno podría surgir de ese puñado
de fascinerosos
por eso el 2 de abril de 1982 los
argentinos fuimos sorprendidos y
sentimos mucha desconfianza
malvinas siempre fue un sentimiento
clavado en el corazón de muchas
generaciones de argentinos y argentinas
y no podemos dejar de celebrar que
nuestra bandera ondeará en aquellas
tierras con los días el intento de
manipulación fue haciéndose evidente
desembarcar en las islas
fue una decisión
a espaldas de un pueblo al que solo lo
intentaron confundir y manipular
que estamos bien
muy bien
pero nuestros soldados no lo vieron de
ese modo
se enfrentaron a una potencia militar de
primer orden con escasos medios pero con
una enorme valentía
con un coraje inigualable y también con
el apoyo del pueblo
defendieron su tierra que
lamentablemente el continuo ha usurpado
muchos jóvenes dejaron sus vidas en una
guerra absolutamente desigual
mostraron coraje
gallardía
aún en la derrota dieron pruebas de una
extraordinaria entereza
reconocida por el mismo ejército que los
encías
no nos cansemos de repetirlos honor a
nuestros soldados de la guerra del
atlántico sur
ahora nuestros soldados de la guerra del
atlántico sur honor
tenemos cientos y miles de testimonios
del valor y de las penurias que debieron
afrontar
si le da en el informe rattenbach que
cristina hizo público en su momento
podrán contactar las numerosas torpezas
y los desastres que la conducción
militar cometió a lo largo de aquel
conflicto
del mismo modo que despreciaron las
leyes y la vida desde el gobierno lo
hicieron cuando condujeron la guerra
debemos también decirlo aquellos
militares que avergonzaron a nuestras
fuerzas armadas hoy definitivamente
constituyen un pasado al que nadie
quiere volver en especial sus camaradas
de armas lo hemos logrado
cabe recordar serlo lo hemos logrado por
mandato popular por comprensión
histórica y por decisión política
nuestra independencia de españa a la
argentina y ejerció la soberanía de las
islas malvinas el 3 de enero de 1833
como hemos visto en el vídeo que nos
precedió
el reino unido- en plena expansión
colonial desalojó violentamente a los
representantes del gobierno argentina y
a sus pobladores y estableció otra
prueba de población proveniente de la
propia metrópolis
esto constituyó un quebrantamiento de la
integridad territorial de nuestro país
desde el mismo momento de la usurpación
argentina ha venido reclamando
ininterrumpidamente por la restitución
del ejercicio pleno de soberanía sobre
nuestras islas en 1994 ese reclamo fue
incorporado por unanimidad a la
constitución nacional la cuestión
malvinas no debe ser cuestión de un
gobierno es una política de estado que
se funda en el mandato de la disposición
transitoria primera de la constitución
nacional a 40 años del conflicto del
atlántico sur
lanzamos la agenda malvinas 40 años y
hemos declarado el año 2022 como un año
de homenaje del pueblo argentino a los
caídos a sus familiares y a los
veteranos y veteranos de malvinas
seguimos denunciando ante el mundo que
se trata de uno de los últimos resabios
de capitalismo de colonialismo también
ambas cosas son parecidas lo dijimos
siempre y lo volvemos a decir hoy 40
años después las malvinas fueron son y
serán argentinas
veremos
el compromiso asumido con los veteranos
y las veteranas
y la memoria de los caídos en sostener
la política de identificación en
nuestros soldados que dejaron su vida en
esa parte del territorio nacional
el gobierno le ha expresado al comité
internacional de la cruz roja el interés
de la república argentina en la
concreción de una tercera etapa de
identificación de caídos en el marco del
segundo plan de proyecto humanitario que
suscribimos en marzo del 2021
han pasado 40 años hoy el mundo se
conmueve por la guerra en europa
imágenes de muerte y destrucción ocupan
un espacio relevante en los medios de
comunicación y en las redes sociales en
ese contexto la república argentina
reitera su búsqueda de una solución
negociada y pacífica a la disputa de la
soberanía
porque tenemos un objetivo irrenunciable
recuperar el ejercicio pleno de
soberanía sobre nuestras islas malvinas
seguiremos trabajando en el marco del
más profundo respeto al derecho
internacional
seguiremos trabajando para recuperar lo
que nos corresponde
seguiremos trabajando por nuestro
derecho
seguiremos trabajando por la memoria de
las víctimas
desde aquí con el respeto y firmeza que
sienten todos los argentinos y las
argentinas como presidente de la nación
argentina
solicitó al reino unido de la gran
bretaña que cumpla con la resolución
2065 de la asamblea general de las
naciones unidas del año 1965
esa resolución nos impone proseguir sin
demora las negociaciones sobre la
disputa de soberanía
estamos pidiendo dialogar en el marco
del derecho internacional que nos asiste
solicitamos también al reino unido de
gran bretaña que abandone la
injustificada y desmedida presencia
militar en esas islas que no hace más
que traer atención a una región
caracterizada por ser una zona de paz y
de cooperación internacional
vaya también nuestro agradecimiento y
reconocimiento a todos los países que
nos vienen acompañando en estos reclamos
en todos los foros internacionales
en especial a las naciones hermanas de
nuestra américa latina y el caribe
porque las malvinas argentinas también
son latinoamericanas
los argentinos hoy
renovamos nuestros sentimientos y
nuestras convicciones
malvinas nos une
hola a quienes perdieron la vida
defendiendo ese territorio
reconocimiento a los veteranos y
veteranas que lucharon incansablemente
en la guerra del atlántico sur
construyamos todos los días la argentina
o avenida que tanto necesitamos y que
nos merecemos
hagamos que de la memoria de este día
y de aquellos que pelearon y dieron su
vida sea la fuente de inspiración para
lograr la argentina- del orgullo de la
que hablaban gisela y román el a
y el futuro común que nos merecemos
viva la patria gracias a todos y todas
[Aplausos]